[Musique]
je me présente je suis Roger fiaméti et
je fais
ostéopathe donc faire avoir être sont
des verbes auxiliaires qui sont
intéressants alors je vais vous
parlerorgage émotionnel du corps et le
thème c'est aujourd'hui devenir
quelqu'un d'autre bien moi je vais vous
proposer de devenir quelqu'un d'autre
d'autre en devenant vous-même redevenir
soi-même mon métier c'est ostéopathe et
c'est vrai que au fur et à mesure de mon
exercice de ma profession j'ai observer
chez les patients pas mal de réactions
on travaille le viscéral on travaille le
structurel on travaille le crânien et
j'ai ajouter une corde à mon arc c'est
l'émotionnel alors l'émotionnel c'est
quoi ça veut dire beaucoup de choses et
je vais vous proposer une grille de
lecture intéressante à travers le corps
et le corps est notre meilleur outil
pour nous reconnaître on a des miroirs
on se regarde tous les matins dans le
miroir et quand on se regarde on voit
pas
grandchose regardez-vous une fois dans
le miroir regardez-vous dans les yeux et
vous verrez peut-être quelqu'un d'autre
et peut-être vous-même alors comment
devenir soi-même et bien en essayant de
se connaître
la belle phrase de Socrate connais-toi
toi-même et tu connaîtras l'univers et
les dieux aller au fond de soi aller au
fond de son de ces émotions aller dans
cette introspection qui permet
d'éliminer les tensions qu'on a accumulé
depuis la vie int utérine jusqu'à
aujourd'hui l'aventure a commencé en
2004 mais déjà bien avant et ce livre a
permis déjà
de lire en soi un livre on le lit mais
le meilleur livre que vous ayez jamais
lu à votre avis c'est
lequel la
Bible certainement oui oui
sûrement le Lage émotionnel du corps pas
encore et bien le meilleur livre que
vous ayez pu lire et j'espère qu'un jour
vous le ferez c'est votre au corps lire
son corps lire à travers cette grille de
lecture comment le corps va réagir au
niveau émotionnel comment le corps va
réagir au
niveau de la peau au niveau des
articulations au niveau des organes ceci
ce sont d'autres ouvrages qui ont été
publiés et que vous pourrez retrouver
sur Amazon par exemple c'est y all les
carartte du l'orgage émotionnel du corps
il y a la respiration pour tous il y a
le longage émotionnel du corps tome a et
et cetera donc ça vous retrouvvez
facilement ça pourra un peu éter vos
lectures le langage du corps le corps
parle que nous
dit-il que peut-on voir à travers le
corps bien c'est une question de point
de
vue qui voit la jeune fille sur le
dessin levez la main qui voit la vieille
dame sur le
dessin qui voit les deux bien les deux
cerveaux sont en connexion qui ne voit
rien aucune des
deux une fois j'ai eu coup dans une
conférence et la dame m'a dit mais je
suis
aveugle peut-être que ça le permettait
de mieux voir en elle
d'ailleurs qui voit le canard à gauche
levez la main qui voit le
lapin qui voit les deux il y a déjà
moins de main levé hein qui voit le bébé
à
droite pas beaucoup hein vous voyez son
estz là près de la branche ses fesses là
près des deux person personnage oui la
tête audessus voilà donc la vie ça
dépend aussi de notre façon de voir les
choses un événement va être différent
selon son positionnement selon son
éducation selon ses expériences je me
promène à la campagne avec un ami ah ça
sent le pur je dis ça sent bon mon AM
dit tu es fou ça so mauvais mais non
parce que pour moi ça correspond à une
odeur de ferme quand j'allais chez mes
grands parents quand j'étais petit donc
pour moi dans mon cerveau Labique ça
correspond à du bonheur pour mon copain
ça correspond à des travaux de ferme qu'
faisait chez son voisin en été et il dev
ramasser le purin pour lui c'était plus
pénible donc la même odeur va libérer
des sensations différentes alors cette
découverte en Finlande par exemple si
vous avez av entendu parler permet de
déterminer des zones au niveau du corps
par rapport à des émotions donc
l'angoisse la colère la peur permet par
cette technique par cette analyse par
thermographie vous voyez les Z jaune
rouge et ce c'est la peau à certains ro
du corps qui augmente température donc
on est dans une relation une réaction
neurovégétative et la réaction
neurovégétative en fait c'est une
augmentation d'adrénaline ou de
neuradrénaline par rapport à danger par
rapport à un stress ou une émotion alors
il y a les émotions et les stress comme
la douleur d'ailleurs la douleur qui est
aigu et puis a la douleur chronique
comme il y a le stress aigu vous êtes
face un danger il y a un stress qui vous
permet de fouir ou de combattre et puis
y a la douleur il y a la douleur
chronique ou le danger chronique c'est
le stress chronique c'est celui qui est
là tout le temps tous les matins quand
je me lève j'ai pas envie d'aller à
l'école tous les jours à midi à table
mon père me regarde dans les yeux et ça
m'empêche de manger quand je dois
revenir avec mon bulletin à la fin de la
période j'ai le stress de rentré ce sont
des stress chroniques et qui restent
entretenus au niveau du corps et qui
créent cette libération de d'adrénaline
et quand ça devient chronique c'est
surtout libération de cortisol qui est
la cortisone endogène et la création de
cortiso ça permet de lutter contre le
stress chronique mais à la longue
l'effet péjoratif c'est que vous avez
une diminution de l'immunité donc la
porte ouverte à toutes les maladies
psychosomatiques donc le stress qui
n'est pas exprimé çaprime et va créer
des cristallisations au niveau des
tissus des nœuds émotionnels qu'on va
pouvoir d'abord par notre grille de
lecture détecter et vous voyez ici au
niveau de la colonne je suis ostéopathe
donc je travaille sur mon clavier si
j'étais pianiste je vous jurai à
concerto de Chopin ou de Mozart ici mon
clavier c'est la colonne vertébrale donc
donc chaque vertèbre va correspondre à
une émotion alors quand j'ai mon patient
qui est sur la table et que je dis ah ça
c'est vous AZ de la colère il y a de
l'abandon et l'humiliation ça vous dit
quelque chose ah comment vous savez ça
vous êtes un voyant je dis non je suis
un lecteur et mon tableau de lecture
c'est votre colonne vertébrale donc il y
a toujours une relation entre les
vertèbres et les émotions qu'on a pu à
travers cette grille de lecture
intéressante mettre en évidence et
chaque individu
va marquer va être marqué dans son corps
en fonction de ce qu'il a vécu il n'y a
pas de hasard le corps ne se trompe pas
quand le patient ne parle plus et ça
arrive souvent avec des adolescents qui
viennent en en séance ils vont chez le
psy puis après trois séance chez le psy
disent-moi j'ai rien à dire j'ai plus
envie de parler alors souvent le psy
pour l'adolescent c'est un tocar
évidemment parce que il va pas dire
qu'il est sympa alors les parents
viennent avec chez moi ou chez d'autres
collègue et quand l'individu est souvent
l' do ou parfois d'autres personnes plus
âgées ne parl plus n'a plus rien à dire
son corps a encore quelque chose à dire
et l'intérêt finalement de la technique
c'est que le corps ne ment pas le corps
ne se trompe pas et le corps révèle
parfois des informations dont on a même
pas conscience puisqu'elles viennent de
l'inconscient donc cette cristallisation
en fait c'est la mise en évidence de
l'inconscient à travers les tissus c'est
la mémoire cellulaire on a la relation
aussi entre le les organes et les
vertèbres ça c'est neurovégétatif c'est
c'est anatomique c'est
neuroanatomique et on peut avoir
aussi la relation entre les organes et
les émotions quand on a un problème
pulmonaire évidemment il y a les
infections hein si vous avez un problème
de bronchitez pas avoir un ostéopathe
somatoémotionnel allez voir le
pneumologue ou votre médecin d'abord
mais si au bout de x traitement ou si
vous sentez tu es étouffé
psychologiquement là il faut pas prendre
un antibiotique il faut peut-être aller
voir au fond des choses où à commencer
l'étouffement et l'étouffement ça
correspond à la deuxième dorsale ici un
peu entre les omoplates en haut il y a
l'estomac qui est en relation avec les
conflits familiaux donc il y a des
personnes qui ont des gastrites qu'on
appelle ou qu'on nomme nerveuse ou des
des gastrites de stress ou des ulcères
de stress ils font tous les traitements
antiacides ils font tous les traitements
chez le gastro malgré tout ça ne passe
pas puis quand on a arrive à libérer le
stress par leur corps qui est inscrit
notamment au niveau des vertèbres en
relation avec l'estomac qu'on va
détecter qu'on va décrypter et qu'on
libère souvent un conflit familial le
fait d'en parler ou de l'identifier ça
permet au patient d'en parler le fait de
se libérer il va libérer son stress et
en libérant son stress il va guérir son
ulcère de stress voyez alors on a ça
avec tous les les organes je va pas vous
les passer tous en revue le foi c'est la
peur de manquer la peur de mourir la
peur peur de ne pas s'en sortir on
parlait tout à l'heure des examens de
fin d'année c'est les examens de passage
le passage il est parfois étro ça vous
fait penser à quoi les passag
TR permis de
conduire quoi
d'autre la naissance on passe tous par
là alors ah désolé moi je suis né par
césarienne c'est la
désincarcération hein quand on fait un
accident parfois les pompiers viennent
ils ouvent la voiture et il vous sort ça
c'est la la
césarienne alors comment est-ce qu'on
peut dire parce que bon c'est facile de
d'en parler mais comment est-ce qu'on
peut dire que les émotions vont
s'inscrire au
niveau du corps à travers des tissus qu
sont ces tissus ce sont des faciens les
fasciens sont des tissus qui vont capter
qui vont enregistrer les sensations les
chocs émotionnels VC inutéux déjà les
émotions de la mère quand elle est
enceinte la parturiante va transmettre
les émotions à son fétus on voit déjà
des des publicité on voit la maman qui
mange un yogourt ou au chocolat et on
voit le le féus à l'intérieur qui est
tout content les publicitaires ont bien
compris le le message et l'ont bien
transmis et ces émotions passent à
travers les fasia qui sont des tissus
très subtiles vous allez voir après des
images et quand le fettus n'a pas encore
de cerveau de Cortex formé jusqu'à 6 ans
quand il est bébé et cetera petit enfant
tout passe par le système Labi et par
les C sens donc c'est toujours lesessens
loui le tact l'audition et cetera qui
capte les infos nous sommes des radars
on reçoit des infos on est transformé
par ces infos où on est figé par ces
infos par ces peur de ne pas s'en sortir
par peur de ne pas y arriver voilà les
fameux faciard dont je vous parle ce
sont des tissus vraiment qui absorb
toutes les tensions et qui partent de la
peau jusque dans les EAU la peau les
muscles les os les organes tout ça ce
sont des facias organisé de nature
différentes mais toujours en continuité
quand je tire sur mes cheveux quand je
tire sur ma peau je peux avoir une
influence jusqu'en bas quand je suis à
la surface je suis à la profondeur donc
on est toujours dans cette dimension
profonde du corps alors l'approche
émotionnelle par cette grille de lecture
va permettre de lire en nous de mieux
nous connaître par exemple D1 vous voyez
ici le point bleu au niveau de la nuque
c'est lié à la peur de perdre la peur de
ne pas s'en sortir c'est la sensation de
sans issu on voit de l'accouchement
quand le bébé va être expulsé mais que
le col n'est pas encore assez ouvert ou
alors parfois quand les mamans les
parturiantes arrivent à la maternité et
qu'on leur dit attendez attendez gyco va
arriver fa qu'elle serre les gens parce
que le bébé va sortir et lui il est prêt
à sortir et on ferme la porte c'est la
notion de sans issue c'est l'examen de
passage fin
d'année il faut passer
c'est le passage on revient au passage
de sa naissance et la première dorsale
comme par hasard quand elle est en
lésion on est fatigué le matin on sait
pas se concentrer on 5 rien alors
qu'est-ce qu'on fait on étudie le matin
de l'examen comme ça on garde tout et
puis on arrive à l'examen et on dit tout
on a tout oublié quand ça marche parce
que vous savez comme moi que quand il a
page donc-ce qu'on fait quand on la
corrige on retrouve son potentiel on
redevient soi-même on a plus peur de
perdre on a plus peur de ne pas s'en
sortir parce qu'on retrouve ses
capacités alors ce n'est pas
psychologique c'est neuro végétatif
puisque au niveau da il y a le ganglion
stellaire qui commande l'artère carotide
qui alimente le cerveau en oxygène donc
quand est rétabli moi j'ai eu un enfant
par exemple de 12 ans don 10 ans à Noël
3/1 de moyenne on dit au parent voilà
votre enfant l'année prochaine on met
dans le spécial
ils viennent on corrige accouchement
difficile comme par hasard qui s'est
impacté en D on corrige d fin de l'année
tête de classe 9/ 10 là le professeur
est un peu B1 donc tant mieux tant mieux
pour l'enfant la petite enfance va
évidemment être aussi une source
d'information et évidemment les
madeleines de Prous on se fait agresser
petit on se fait agresser grand on
apprend à marcher petit on a peur on
perd la marche plus âgé on a peur donc
c'est toujours un événement du passé qui
reste en foui en nous et qui ressurgit
dans le présent mais de façon comme un
tsunami de façon démesurée et c'est là
qu'on se rend compte qu'il y a un choc
émotionnel qui n'a pas été exprimé parce
que quand le présent vous amène une
situation de stress ou de danger on on
réagit et si par hasard on ne sait pas
réagir c'est parce qu'on a vraiment une
émotion qui revient du passé qui a pas
été gérée qui est cristallisée et qui
n'est pas
libéré donc là c'est la technique où je
ne fais pas de mouvement je ne fais que
recueillir le mouvement qui vient des
tissus des fcias les Fas qui bougent et
je les accompagne et en les accompagnant
on laisse le corps décristalliser les
tensions qui se sont inscrites à 3 ans à
6 ans à 9 ans à 12 ans à 6 mois inutéro
il faut savoir qu' 6 semaines initéro il
y a déjà le réflexe de peur paralysante
qui s'inscrit sur l'embrion si la mère
vit des émotions de peur ou de stress
voilà devenir quelqu'un d'autre soi-même
moin les peur et moi les souffrances ça
vous permettra de mieux exister et
d'être quelqu'un d'autre c'est-à-dire
vous-même merci pour votre
attention